THOSE OF YOU THAT WERE NOT
EVACUATED
>> JOINING US NOW WITH MUCH MORE
ON WHAT HIS STATE IS NOW FACING
IS FLORIDA SENATOR MARCO RUBIO
IS WITH US.
SENATOR FIRST OUR PRAYERS, OUR
THOUGHTS ARE WITH OUR FELLOW
AMERICANS, OUR FLORIDIAN
FRIENDS, SORRY YOU'RE ALL GOING
THROUGH THIS.
THIS IS A ROUGH ONE.
WHAT DO YOU KNOW ESPECIALLY
ABOUT SOUTHWEST FLORIDA, WHAT
HAPPENED NAPLES, FORT MYERS, ET
CETERA, SARASOTA?
>> WELL, I THINK THE REPORTING
THAT PRECEDED ME ON THE AIR KIND
OF DESCRIBES THE IMAGES WE'RE
GOING TO BEGIN TO SEE TOMORROW.
WE KNOW THAT THE STORM SURGE IS
VERY SIGNIFICANT, HISTORIC
REALLY AND I THINK WE'RE ALL
GOING TO BE SHOCKED BY SOME OF
THE IMAGES THAT ARE GOING TO
EMERGE.
ONE OF THE WATER GAUGES THAT
MEASURES IN FORT MYERS WAS HIGH
AN HOUR AGO AND RAPIDLY RISING
SO THERE'S STILL A THREAT THERE
AND EVEN AS WE'RE DEALING WITH
THAT, WE RECOGNIZE THIS STORM IS
NOT MOVING INLAND AND NOW WE
MOVE TO A SECOND KIND OF RISK
AND THAT IS THE FLASH FLOOD.
THE NATIONAL WEATHER SERVICE HAS
ISSUED ITS HIGHEST ALERT
POSSIBLE, EXPECTING UPWARDS IN
SOME ISOLATED AREAS OF UP TO 12
INCHES OF RAIN BUT CERTAINLY
FOUR TO EIGHT INCHES.
SO THEY'RE NOW TALKING ABOUT
REAL FLASH FLOOD THREAT IN MANY
PARTS OF CENTRAL FLORIDA AS THIS
STORM MOVES IN THE OVERNIGHT
HOURS.
AND THE WORRY THERE OF COURSE IS
IT'S OVERNIGHT.
SOME PEOPLE WILL BE ASLEEP,
MIGHT BE IN THE WAY OF THESE
FLASH FLOOD ADVISORIES COMING
THEIR WAY BUT A LOT OF RAIN
THAT'S GOING TO COME THROUGH
CENTRAL FLORIDA AND NORTHEAST
FLORIDA.
SO TOMORROW'S GOING TO BE
ANOTHER TERRIBLE DAY FOR FLORIDA
FOR PEOPLE IN EASTERN CENTRAL
FLORIDA ALL THE WAY UP TO THE
NORTHEAST PART OF THE COAST,
EVEN AS WE BEGIN TO SEE THE
IMAGES EMERGE TOMORROW FROM
SOUTHWEST FLORIDA AND THE DAMAGE
THAT WAS DONE THERE, THESE FLASH
FLOODS OVER THE NEXT FEW HOURS
AND INTO THE EARLY HOURS OF
TOMORROW ARE NOTHING TO PLAY
WITH, THEY'RE VERY SIGNIFICANT,
THE THREAT IS VERY HIGH,
PROBABLY THE HIGHEST IT'S EVER
BEEN CERTAINLY THAT I CAN RECALL
IN SUCH A WIDE SWATH AREA.
>> Sean: I KNOW THERE'S'S BEEN A
LOT OF COORDINATION BETWEEN YOU
GOVERNOR DeSANTIS, SENATOR RICK
SCOTT, YOU HAVE MOBILIZED EVERY
SINGLE AGENCY WITHIN THE STATE
OF FLORIDA PREPARING THIS,
KNOWING THAT IT WAS LIKELY GOING
TO BE THIS BAD.
I WAS PRETTY IMPRESSED, I SAW AN
AP PICTURE TODAY, AND IT HAD
WHAT LOOKED LIKE THREE OR
4--LOOK AT THIS POOR GUY
SWIMMING INSIDE HIS LIVING ROOM.
THAT HOME IS PROBABLY GOING TO
HAVE TO BE REBUILT.
BUT YOU PRE POSITIONED AND
STAGED ALL THESE ELECTRIC
COMPANY TRUCKS ARE ON STAND-BY
LITERALLY TO FLOOD INTO FLORIDA.
I SAW A PICTURE, LOOKED LIKE
THREE FOOTBALL FIELD'S WORTH OF
UTILITY TRUCKS READY TO GO IN
AND MAKE THE REPAIRS THAT WILL
BE DESPERATELY NEEDED IN THE
DAYS TO COME.
THAT'S PRETTY IMPRESSIVE STAGING
AND PRE POSITIONING, I WOULD
SAY, FOR THE STATE OF FLORIDA.
WE CAN SHOW THAT BIG PICTURE
THAT I SENT OVER EARLIER TODAY.
>> YEAH.
SO PART OF IT IS NOW, AS WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT EARLIER, SOME OF
THE UTILITY COMPANIES ARE MAKING
AND IN SOME OF THESE AREAS THE
GRID IS NOT GOING TO BE REPAIRED
IT MAY HAVE TO BE COMPLETELY
REBUILT WHICH OF COURSE WILL
EXTEND THE TIME FRAME THAT WILL
TAKE, THAT'S A SERIOUS THREAT.
YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT, FLORIDA
UNFORTUNATELY BECAUSE WE'VE BEEN
THROUGH SO MANY STORMS HAS GOOD
SYSTEMS IN PLACE, THE GOVERNOR
HAS DONE A GOOD JOB ORGANIZING
THAT, THE MERGE SIT MANAGEMENT,
AND FEMA'S BEEN VERY COOPERATIVE
AND WILL COME IN AND BACK
WHATEVER THE STATE NEEDS.
BUT THERE'S A LOT OF WORK TO BE
DONE, WE DON'T EVEN KNOW THE
EXTENT OF IT, YOU HAVE TO CLEAR
THE ROADS AND GET THE CREWS IN
THERE AND SAVE LIVES.
LEE COUNTY THEIR 911 SYSTEM IS
COMPLETELY DOWN BEING REROUTED
TO COL YEAR THEY ARE GETTING
CALLS THAT WE CAN'T RESPOND TO
BECAUSE IT'S NOT SAFE TO GET TO
AND ALMOST THE ENTIRE COUNTY'S
OUT OF POWER.
WE HAVE MULTIPLE COUNTIES WHERE
THERE'S NO POWER WHATSOEVER.
SO WE DON'T KNOW SOME OF THE
HARROWING THINGS GOING ON RIGHT
NOW.
BUT THESE CREWS ARE READY TO GO
AND WE THANK THEM, FROM ALL OVER
THE COUNTRY READY TO GO, BUT IT
NEEDS TO BE SAFE BEFORE WE CAN
MOVE IN AND THAT'S GOING TO TAKE
AT LEAST ANOTHER 24-36 HOURS
BEFORE WORK CAN EVEN BEGIN IN
THESE PARTS.
>> WE KNOW THAT, LET'S SAY
WEATHER FORECASTING IS AN
IMPORTANT SCIENCE, MOST MODELS
LEADING INTO TODAY, AND I'M NOT
BLAMING EVERYBODY, EVERYBODY'S
DOING THE BEST JOB THEY CAN, HAD
THIS STORM HITTING A LITTLE BIT
MORE NORTH, MORE TOWARDS THE
TAMPA AREA.
IT CAME IN A LITTLE BIT
SOUTHWEST, AND THAT BEING
NAPLES, THAT BEING FORT MYERS,
THAT BEING SARASOTA.
BUT YOU STILL HAD 2.5 MILLION
PEOPLE THAT WERE IN THE
EVACUATION ZONE.
THAT'S A LOT OF PEOPLE TO MOVE.
IN SOME OF THESE AREAS PEOPLE
DID NOT EVACUATE AND MY
UNDERSTANDING IS, IS THAT THERE
ARE REQUESTS OUT THERE LOOKING
FOR PEOPLE, IF YOU HAVE ANY
INFORMATION ABOUT ANYBODY THAT
MAY BE IN TROUBLE, AS SOON AS
THEY'RE ABLE, THEY WANT TO SEND
THEM IN.
DO YOU KNOW ANYTHING ABOUT THOSE
EFFORTS?
>> YEAH FLORIDA DISASTER.ORG, IF
YOU GO ON THAT WEB SITE, FLORIDA
DISASTER.ORG YOU'RE GOING TO BE
ABLE TO GO TO A SITE WHERE YOU
CAN REGISTER, WHETHER YOU'RE ONE
OF THOSE PEOPLE THAT STAYED
BEHIND OR YOU KNOW SOMEONE THAT
DID SO IT GIVES SPOT WORKERS A
CENSUS THAT THEY CAN BEGIN TO
CHECK ON AND GET INFORMATION
ABOUT THE HOUSEHOLDS.
LOOK I THINK MOST PEOPLE DID
LEAVE, AS YOU KNOW A LOT OF
PEOPLE KNOW THAT PART OF OUR
STATE IS SOMEWHAT SEASONAL SO IT
DOESN'T HAVE THEIR FULL
POPULATION BUT THERE'S STILL A
LOT OF PEOPLE THERE.
HOPEFULLY MANY OF THEM LEFT,
SOUNDS LIKE MOST OF THEM LEFT
BUT THESE VIDEOS ARE COMING FROM
SOMEBODY, THERE ARE PEOPLE THAT
STAYED BEHIND AND RIGHT NOW IF
YOU'RE IN LEE COUNTY OR EVEN
COLLIER COUNTY, BUT ESPECIALLY
LEE COUNTY AND YOU ARE TRAPPED
BY WATER THERE IS NO WAY TO GET
TO YOU.
IT'S ONE OF THE REASONS WE DO
THESE EVACUATION ORDERS.
YOU JUST HAVE TO HANG ON AND DO
THE BEST YOU CAN BECAUSE
HOPEFULLY SOME POINT TOMORROW
THE RESCUE CREWS CAN COME OUT
AND RESPOND.
CONDITIONS ARE STILL NOT SAFE.
ONCE THAT HAPPENS YOU'RE GOING
TO SEE SOMETHING UNPRECEDENTED,
THEY'LL COME BY AIR, BY BOAT,
VOLUNTEER GROUPS LIKE THE CAJUN
NAVY READY TO GO.
THEY'RE READY TO MOVE.
>> Sean: LET ME ASK YOU, IF
ANYBODY IN THIS AUDIENCE KNOWS
OF SOMEBODY THAT DIDN'T EVACUATE
CURRENTLY IN AN AREA AND THEY
CAN'T GET OUT, IF YOU GO TO THE
WEB SITE THAT SENATOR RUBIO JUST
MENTIONED,
FLORIDADISASTER.ORG/INFO AND YOU
INPUT THE NAME OF THE PERSON AND
THE ADDRESS THAT THE PERSON IS
AT, IF THEY CONTACTED YOU AND
SAID THIS IS REALLY BAD HERE AND
I CAN'T GET OUT OF HERE, YOU CAN
PUT THEIR NAME AND ADDRESS ON
THAT WEB SITE AND THEN RESCUERS
WILL KNOW EXACTLY WHERE TO GO TO
HELP THEM OUT.
THOSE EFFORTS, HOPEFULLY,
SENATOR, CAN START TOMORROW.
LET'S TALK ABOUT OTHER RESCUE
EFFORTS THAT ARE GOING TO BE
NEEDED HERE AND ALSO THE
COORDINATION AS IT RELATES TO
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT, YOU
MENTIONED FEMA.
I KNOW THE WHITE HOUSE HAS BEEN
IN TOUCH WITH YOU AND GOVERNOR
DeSANTIS.
WHAT IS THE LATEST ON THEIR
EFFORTS TO HELP?
>> WELL, LOOK, FEMA'S PRE
POSITIONED, EVERYTHING IN THE
STATE IS NEEDED, FEMA'S READY TO
PROVIDE AS A BACK STOP OR TO ADD
ON BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY THE STATE
HAS ITS OWN SUPPLIES THEY'RE THE
PRIMARY RESPONDERS BUT THEY'LL
NEED MORE AND THEN ARMY CORPS IS
READY TO GO.
I TALKED WITH FEMA DIRECTOR THIS
AFTERNOON ABOUT HELP REMOVING
DEBRIS FROM THE ROAD TO GET
PEOPLE IN, WE'LL NEED HEAVY
EQUIPMENT.
BUT THE MOST IMPORTANT THING IF
HE HASN'T DONE SO, AND I EXPECT
HE WILL, THE PRESIDENT WILL
APPROVE THE MAJOR DISASTER
DECLARATION.
I LED THE ENTIRE FLORIDA
DELEGATION IN SENDING A LETTER
IN SUPPORT OF GOVERNOR DeSANTIS'
REQUEST BECAUSE THAT WILL ALLOW
FOR INDIVIDUAL ASSISTANCE.
NOW THE INDIVIDUAL, WHO, FOR
EXAMPLE, HAS NO HOME TO GO BACK
TO WILL NOW BE ABLE TO APPLY TO
FEMA AND QUICKLY GET THE
ASSISTANCE THEY NEED, FIND A
PLACE TO LIVE, FIND A WAY TO
FEED THEMSELVES WHILE WE WORK
THROUGH THIS.
AND THE SAME WILL BE TRUE FOR
SMALL BUSINESSES THROUGH THE
SBAs, I EXPECT THAT DECLARATION
IF IT HASN'T BEEN MADE WILL COME
SHORTLY AND THAT WILL OPEN THE
DOOR FOR THE INDIVIDUAL
ASSISTANCE.
I THINK IT'S REALLY TOUGH TO
TELL YOU WE'VE SEEN
[AUDIO DISRUPTION]
>> WATER DAMAGE AND SURGE IN
SOUTHWEST FLORIDA, A TREMENDOUS
AMOUNT OF FLOOD DAMAGE IN
CENTRAL FLORIDA INCLUDING
AGRICULTURAL AREAS AND RURAL
AREAS THAT THERE MIGHT BE SOME
PEOPLE WE DON'T EVEN KNOW ARE
THERE YET BECAUSE THEY DIDN'T
SIGN UP BEFOREHAND AND SO FORTH.
BUT A LOT OF PEOPLE READY TO
HELP, THE CONDITIONS HAVE TO BE
RIGHT BUT WHEN THAT HAPPENS
YOU'LL SEE THE HELP COME.
>> Sean: AND BY THE WAY ANYBODY
AROUND THE COUNTRY, I KNOW
AMERICANS ALWAYS STEP UP AND
HELP THEIR FELLOW AMERICANS IN
NEED, THEY HAVE SET UP A WEB
SITE THAT YOU CAN GIVE DONATIONS
TO OBVIOUSLY.
IT'S FLORIDA DISASTER FUND.ORG
IS THE OFFICIAL ONE.
AGAIN, IF YOU KNOW ANYBODY THAT
DIDN'T EVACUATE, SOMEBODY THAT
IS TRAPPED, YOU CAN GO TO
FLORIDADISASTER.ORG/INFO, INPUT
THE PERSON'S NAME AND ADDRESS
AND RESCUERS KNOW EXACTLY WHERE
TO GO.
I KNOW THIS HAS BEEN A BUSY DAY
FOR YOU SENATOR, AND
COORDINATION AND THE
PREPAREDNESS SEEMS TO BE AS GOOD
AS ANY I'VE EVER SEEN SO WE WISH
EVERYBODY IN FLORIDA THE BEST.
OUR PR